it is time for me to scoop leaves
would you like to help sure
i like a clean pond
and so do the fish
[Music]
hey there
my name's jessica skye and i'm super
excited for what you have planned today
but first let's pause for a second
can you hear my wind chimes
[Music]
i love listening to that sound it always
makes me feel so happy and calm
and so many interesting things can
happen when we just pay attention to
what's happening around us
and inside us
like with our breath
let's try it together remember that mat
or towel you grabbed earlier it's time
to roll it out on the floor
so free to move your pillow if you need
to
and it's fine if you don't have a mat or
towel just find a safe flat surface
now have a seat and get comfortable
we're gonna take three nice long breaths
in through the nose
and out through the mouth
two more and do it with me
inhaling
exhaling
last one
deep breath in through your nose
exhaust through your mouth
what are you doing
stillwater says if you have an angry
feeling inside you sit still close your
eyes and take deep slow breaths
it can make you feel better
great job
now
breathing is one of those things that we
do all the time and sometimes we don't
even notice it
but
if you're not feeling great on the
inside
taking a moment to catch your breath can
change that and
really help you feel calm is it working
actually
it is
are you ready to try something new
[Music]
it's called deep belly breathing and
it's one of stillwater's favorites
i like your big belly
me too i'd like you to put one hand
right here on the top of your stomach
just below your ribs
and when you breathe in
do it through your nose
and i want you to try and make your
belly big
and full
it's like
a balloon and we're filling it up with
air
and when it's full
go ahead
and exhale super slowly through your
mouth
let me show you and then let's do it
together
[Music]
ready do this one with me
[Music]
feels good right
let's do it a few more times together
just keep going
[Music]
super calming one more
nice job filling up that balloon very
nice i think you're a natural next i'd
like to ask
what are some of the things you notice
when everything's super quiet there are
many different ways to be mindful in the
world around you let's sit for a moment
and
just listen
and i find sometimes it helps me focus
if i close my eyes
so give it a go
soften your gaze or completely close
your eyes
and just tune in with all those noises
around you
i can hear the water trickling behind me
i can hear the birds chirping in the
distance
and the leaves rustling in the winds
what can you hear
maybe there's a fan blowing air in the
background
a car outside
maybe your family are in the other room
and you can hear them
to take a moment
notice if you can hear
your own
breath
isn't it wonderful
now let's use our eyes this time how do
we start
first start with what you see
the shape of the fruit the colors so
have a look around
i can see
pink flowers
i can see green leaves starting to turn
yellow
i can see a red table
what colors can you find around you in
your space
what color are the walls
maybe there's an object on a desk or a
table
what color is that
maybe even look outside your window
notice what you can see there
there are so many colors in the world
so take a moment
taking them all in
excellent job using your senses
now let's move on to something new go
ahead and stand up on your mat or towel
just like this
if you've got shoes and socks on
go ahead and take them off now
we're going to give our toes something
to do
all set
let's scrunch our toes up
and
notice what we feel
i can feel
tingles in the tips of my toes
what can you feel beneath your toes
is it soft
is anything bunching up between your
toes
maybe you're on wooden floors
or tile
is it cool
is it warm
now let's move up from our feet
to the rest of our body
do you feel the air around you
maybe there's a fan or a heater
and you can feel it blowing air onto
your skin
or maybe you're stood near an open
window and you can feel the breeze
coming in did you feel the cold on your
back that's my favorite part
perhaps the air
in your room is still
try moving your arms slowly around you
i bet you can feel the air now so just
notice
how that feels
it's like the air is moving out of your
way
just like ripples in a pond
all right let's do one more type of
breathing and this is a fun one it's
called b breath that does sound like fun
so you know how bees make a buzzing
sound that's where this breathing gets
its name from
we're going to buzz together like little
bees
so let's take a slow breath in
through our nose
and then this time exhale with the mouth
closed and make a humming sound let me
show you
[Music]
first let's try it together ready
[Music]
feel how your lips vibrate a little bit
and it kind of tickles
you can even put one hand on your belly
like before and i bet it's getting
smaller while you're humming let's try
one more time
[Music]
that's good
now i love how this makes me feel
it relaxes me and it also energizes me
how does it make you feel how does your
face and tummy and chest feel now
it's always important to notice how
you're feeling
both on the inside and the outside
and if you're feeling happy on the
inside that's wonderful
and if you're not
that's okay
but if you take a moment to breathe
it can make you feel a whole lot better
isn't it interesting how these feelings
change when you give them time thank you
so much for sharing this part of your
day with me
[Music]
see
[Music]
you